ich bin peter ramsauer ich lebe mit
meiner familie seit jahrhunderten im
chiemgau und bin seit
31 jahren nicht direkt gewählte
bundestagsabgeordnete
für den chiemgauer das berchtesgadener
land nun den rupertiwinkel
die hochburg der csu liegt im südosten
des freistaats bayern an der grenze zu
österreich im bundestagswahlkreis
traunstein konnte die partei vor vier
jahren 44 6 prozent der zweitstimmen
erhalten bei den erststimmen konnte sich
peter ramsauer mit 50,3 prozent
durchsetzen er tritt dieses jahr zum
neunten mal als direktkandidat für die
csu
was ist ihr erfolgsrezept für eine lange
politische karriere
alle politische kraft eines politischen
mandat ist geht vom wahlkreis aus und
wer das vergisst wie schnell weg vom
fenster das habe ich auch schon einige
male lädt wer meint er könne aus dem
wahlkreis zunächst mal kometenhaft
aufsteigen in eine
atemberaubende
galaktisch politische umlaufbahn gehen
verglüht oft sehr schnell habe ich alles
erlebt und römer
boots on the ground heißt zu
militärischen so behält man ein land zu
gewinnen
was macht ihren wahlkreis aus
wir leben hier in einem paradies in
einer unglaublichen wohlfahrt in eine
stabilität
vollbeschäftigung
hervorragende verhältnisse in jeder art
in einer wunderbaren natur
wirtschaftliche stabilität
gute infrastruktur chancen für die
jugend bildung in jeder hinsicht alles
erreichbar jeder seine eigene gute
zukunft das darf nicht darüber
hinwegtäuschen dass wir natürlich in der
operativen detail gestaltung jede menge
herausforderungen an vor welchen
herausforderungen steht ihr wahlkreis
sechsstreifige ausbau auto waren der bei
uns durch geht das anbinden bleiben wir
beim tourismus wenn wir gäste hier haben
wollen die müssen nach ordentliche
herkommen können entweder ordentlich mit
zug oder mit dem auto oder auch mit dem
flugzeug
das muss alles gestaltet werden aber
wenn ich das vergleiche meinen wahlkreis
mit den
298 anderem bundes wahlkreisen in
deutschland dann kann ich nur sagen
mensch peter passt das gut erwischt wie
ticken die menschen in ihrem wahlkreis
das sind kreuz gerade menschen
liberal und konservativ aber
total global weltoffen diese
weltoffenheit gäbe hätten wir auch nicht
diese
grund stabile und werfe wirtschaftliche
stärke so nach kulturelle stärke ist die
union nicht mehr konservativ genug
meine forderung ist immer auch
parteiintern in unserer strategie
diskussionen
und das vollzieht sich entlang der linie
die straße schon immer ausgegeben hat
rechts von der mitte darf es keine
demokratisch legitimierte partei
politische kraft geben als über csu das
haben wir jetzt leider gottes aufs spiel
gesetzt und das problem werden wir noch
lange haben erreicht die csu die wähler
nicht mehr
dieses denken in eisenstadt
wählerschaften also was du da eine
stammwählerschaft hast wie die da unten
gerade gackern
wie hast du das ist doch längst vorbei
ich habe angefangen mit der rechnung 55
prozent plus dann haben wir das ein
bisschen gemäldes auf 50% + ich ja wir
reden heute von 30 prozent fix und die
30 prozent um die muss man sich bemühen
und es ist ein ständiger kampf mit
glaubwürdigkeit mit grund ständig keiten
berechenbarkeit mit einer politik ich
sage es jetzt bewusst einmal im
positiven sinne des sowohl-als-auch es
gibt nicht immer eine wahrheit sondern
immer das sowohl als auch mit maß und
mitte mit besonnenheit das verfängt man
letztlich und da können wir dieses
möglichst große fix über dem 30
gewährleisten